we humans we have a decimal system in
space 1010 digits because we have ten
digits that believe me they're
coordinates
okay now the base-10 system it works
great for us but it doesn't work so
great for computers the reason why is
computers during another figures to
count on right computers only work on
electricity which at least in the
computers that we have is either on or
it's off okay there's electrical current
flowing through a wire or there's no
electrical contractor for your life so
it's on or off now we want to be able to
represent numbers somehow just like we
represent numbers so what do computers
do ok so rather than counting right 0 1
2 3 4 etc right computers can only count
it's kind of like off or on off or on
those are the only two options they've
got ok now think about that for a second
on or off if you just got two numbers
that's like 1 or 0 think about how this
works for counting ok now maybe you want
to write this over here when you've got
decimal we're so familiar with decimal
that we don't think very often about how
it actually works so if you write down a
few numbers with me right
like say 1 2 3 4 5 ok now we associate
these with numbers but actually they're
really they're just shapes it just
shapes okay by the way they all come
back to counting they all come back to
like counting with fingers which is why
if you have a look at what survived got
assistance around the world like say
Japanese sorry I'm right you can
literally see the 1 2 3 literally you
can see the fingers right
Arabic Leros which is always the we use
they're not that different it's just
that when you have a look at the numbers
we just got lazy so we started putting
connecting lines between us
so it all comes back down to it yes
right it's like you know it's just I'm
trying to align now think about this
think about how you would count this
system here we call it binary because
it's only got two options by like
classical thinking about how you would
count now to counter what is easy enough
but zero then you went one but when you
go to the next number right well what
happens in decimal what happens in
decimal when you get to six seven eight
nine you know like I've run out of
shapes to use friend of shapes so what
do I do I go back to the start
right I have to stop reusing symbols
right it's actually the first symbol is
zero so I reused my first two symbols
and I'm like look that's actually not a
one that counts as a tenth okay and we
use place value saying I can it's a new
number so over here it's like okay by
the time I count to one I've already
exhausted all of my symbols but I don't
have anymore shapes to you so I have to
reset I've got to go back to the
beginning so I read that in binary as -
that's how I count - is just that I
don't have a symbol that's designated to
be - okay now this is all right how do I
keep counting in decimal I start to
reuse symbols don't I right so when I
get the next number it's going to be 1 1
and now I've used up all my symbols
having R so what will the next one be
I've got to go to another place value
every time I run out of symbols I have
to go to a new place node so the next
one will be that I've gotta go to there
that's seven that's seven and now I'm
gonna get to eight what am I gonna do
I've run out of shapes right so I need
another place value so okay so this
eight
okay now think about this right you've
got these look at the numbers that
you've got hit in particular I wish you
look at for these ones she's gonna
highlight some okay have a look at these
numbers with me I pulled the map because
they're extra important when you think
in terms of this decimal system right
every time you add a new digit you get
twice not once you get ten times bigger
right so you add a new digit I would
read these as one ten a hundred a
thousand ten thousands you get the idea
okay so every time you had a new digit
in decimal you get ten times bigger but
every time you add an even digit in
binary you don't get ten times bigger
look at the numbers that I've outlined
to us instead of getting ten times maybe
you get you get you get twice as big
right you see I've added a new digit and
now I'm - I've added a new digit Nolan
for another new digit now an eighth
without counting all rest in between you
can probably predict what this number
should be if that's binary it should be
sixteen right and if I read this how
many there we go
that would be 32 I keep doubling and
doubling and doubling you sort of should
expect this because decimal gets ten
times bigger couldn't space 10 but
binary is what we call base yeah - right
so the numbers get bigger by doubling
now here's the problem right we then
need to get humans who come like this
and computers they count like this to
kind of talk to each other right now we
already have this pre-established system
that's all about thousands but this guy
can only work in doubles and that confi
right now because I'm I
if you keep on EE right the next powers
you get are 64 128 256 512 and then or
surprise surprise a thousand and 24 now
be Abed you look at pals of two now
that's 24 is really close to what about
like 10 min of news okay now can you can
actually prove it if you keep on going
you right if I kept a lot
now look at the numbers you're getting
right just just look at these numbers
not many zeros are there right you're
not any Cuesta like a thousand or a
million or something nice and me the
closest one you get is pretty much that
okay so a long time ago computer
engineers were like we have to pick one
of these one of these like a couple he
tells us that's kind of close to alland
so they picked this one it's not a
thousand but it's the closest one we can
get and so now you've inherited a system
that has almost a thousand but not quiet
at least it's better than having to
remember one of these numbers that would
be completely random okay so why is it a
thousand twenty-four it's because
computers can only talk in binary so
everything has to be in terms of doubles
by the way it's the reason why there are
eight bits as well not ten which is what
you think I was like a normal group it
is the closest they could get up to
Tempe okay so this is why computers have
built like this and you have to go
through this somewhat awkward sort of
conversion for yourself
and this is why as well when you have an
if you buy like a when you buy a phone
for example and we say oh yeah it's 128
yo - that's the capacity right because
I'll dig into this a bit more later
because a difference is in the way that
people actually count the file size
notice they actually are obliged to tell
you they have to do this translation in
really
tiny writing like that like you know
terms of conditions may apply there
physically how much is actually stored
on your device or on your memory card or
whatever it is in the units and
everything goes so if you look further
in terms of conditions you'll find that
so I hope thank yous a bit of an
explanation as to why it's a thousand
twenty four not a thousand this also
explains why if you go back to the
formula datasheet give everybody put it
out to you in the middle there it
converts everything to buy it and then
it's got instead of like scientific
notation ten to the power of this to the
part that it's all to to have this or
that it's because all of these numbers
are powers of two ago so this one's to
the power of 1/2 1/2 squared 2 cubed
this one here is to the power of ten
pump it's convenient okay so all of the
numbers that you get are multiples of
this guy